oh good evening nerdfighters it's me
your friend John Green if you're
watching this video that means that I
either am recently was or soon will be
talking over it blog tv.com with Allen
aka fall of autumn distro and hopefully
all of you it's like question Tuesday
only instead of having like a 1 in 400
chance of having your question answered
you have like a 1 in 1 chance
anyway starts at 7:00 p.m. Eastern and
it ends to that like about 9:00 p.m.
Eastern so I hope you come all right
dftba oh I forgot to say link in the
sidebar that's like my catchphrase link
in the sidebar and then I point in the
wrong direction but now I know the right
direction
link in the sidebar yes